Let me ask you a question first about John Barth and the stories that I asked
you to read.
Which of them was your favorite?
Some cackling.
I hear none of them.
Which of them was your favorite lacy journey?
Nitesy journey.
Why?
Um,
I thought it was the profoundest joke I've ever heard.
Hi.
Yes.
Okay.
Very good.
Yes,
that's,
that's a very,
the profoundest joke she has ever heard.
Who else?
Your favorite story?
Yes.
Awesome.
Okay.
Why is that?
I really like the tricks that are played with Kathy rare.
[inaudible].
Yes.
Okay.
What else?
Other favorites?
Yeah.
Did anyone have Ambrose?
His mark as a favorite?
Only one of two of you.
That's extremely surprising.
Um,
why was Ambrose his mark,
not your favorite?
What did you not like about it
anyway?
Yes.
I actually thought it was hard to understand.
Just like what,
what was happening.
The action,
the story
might have been that I read it too quickly.
Harder than mental lab to understand.
No.
Oh,
okay.
Uh,
anyone else on Ambross?
Mark Comments?
When I asked this question typically,
especially when I've had students read the whole thing,
Ambrose is,
mark is almost always the favorite story.
And the reason for that I think is that it is a technically perfect short story.
It has wit,
it has developed characters,
it has a coherent narrative.
Um,
even if it has some,
uh,
difficulties,
that's probably more due to things like dialect.
There's a German immigrant dialect that some of the characters speak.
Um,
it's full of little,
um,
little tropes,
little consistencies,
little images,
the bees,
um,
even the word play skep and skeptical.
Uh,
there are words that mirror some of the major themes of that story about naming
Barth by offering us a perfect short story in that story is demonstrating what
traditional structures of narrative have always offered us and the fact that
it's not your favorite meeting.
Maybe we're at a watershed moment that even traditional narrative can just,
you guys are so well beyond that,
that seduction.
Maybe it's Lolita that we read.
Maybe it's that you've,
you got so seduced by Lolita or you were so well trained to be skeptical of
narrative seduction that now nothing can phase.
You've,
nothing can seduce you.
Maybe that's it.
Give yourself that credit.
Um,
John Barth is a teacher through and through.
He actually taught at my Alma Mater,
Johns Hopkins for over 30 years in the writing program.
And I once got from him I handout that he would give to his fiction classes.
And it had on it,
oh,
the traditional,
uh,
tricks and structures of the short story form.
It was like three or four pages,
single space typed things like,
you know,
if there are five pistols hanging on the wall,
by the end of the story,
they all have to go off,
you know,
these totally structural,
uh,
observations about how to write a piece of short fiction.
Um,
it's so appropriate in my various moves in my life.
I lost this piece of paper and I can,
I have never been able to find it.
And I've tried to be in touch with him about it and I,
and I couldn't get it from him either.
So,
um,
this is one of the sad things about teaching Barth for me.
He was such a teacher.
Um,
I think this story collection is very much a teaching,
uh,
of us about narrative.
Um,
I'm sorry that I can't,
uh,
now produce that as your teacher for you.
Um,
I want to do something that might,
uh,
seem odd
as I begin.
Does this shock anyone?
Do you like having this real sense?
Oh,
don't do that.
If you do,
you're probably taught like me never,
never damaged your book.
Getting in trouble in our house.
If,
if,
if you damaged a book,
you were in big trouble.
Okay?
So what I'm doing is I'm taking the Mobius Strip from the beginning and I am
matching the letters here.
Capital a,
let's see how does it go?
Capital a overlaps with small A.
Capital B overlaps with small B,
tape it together.
Okay,
here we go.
Once upon a time,
there was a story that began once upon a time.
There was a story that began once upon a time.
Okay,
so you get the point.
Why?
Why does Barth put this in the front of his story?
Well,
I think there are several reasons and I'm going to name about three of them.
One is that language is material.
I think we have a visceral response sometimes when you cut a book because
somehow we don't want to be reminded that a story is in a material container,
but he invites us to do this to his story.
So that's the first point,
it's material.
The second point is that narrative has a form and that it can be constructed,
built.
It's like a craft.
I had my little tape and my little scissors,
my little project,
my craft project.
So stories are a craft.
They get built of the material of language.
Last point form is both endless and closed.
It is both repetitious and endlessly filled with possibility
because when you read this in its mobius strip form,
you repeating a beginning over and over and over again.
It gives you that feeling of possibility,
but it's also boring.
This is not an interesting story.
It doesn't tell us anything.
John Barth runs a certain kinds of risk in this story collection and it's the
risk of difficulty.
If I had had you read the whole thing,
you would see even more the kind of risk he's running.
Some of the stories are self consciously boringly,
Mehta,
fictional.
They sound like all those stories we have about somebody writing a story about
themselves,
about themselves writing a story,
who is also writing a story about themselves writing a story.
It's very boring.
There's no kind of life in it.
It's all about that endless regress.
So Barth is taking a risk that this little craft project emphasizes and that the
stories in the book act out.
Hmm.
Why is it worth it to him to take that risk?
What's he trying to teach us about narrative and about language that makes it
worth this risk?
Now,
let me just make the last point I want to make about this and that's that.
Because language is material,
it has form,
it has both closeness and possibility.
It's susceptible to the workings of craft.
It's also unpredictable.
What's going to happen to that now?
Who's going to find it?
It's going to sit there,
it's going to blow from place to place.
Again,
in other stories that I didn't have you read the theme of the message in the
bottle returns over and over again.
The sense that language is material means that it can be separate from people
and have a kind of life of its own.
Now one question for us is,
is the life of its own that Barth dreams of for language similar to that life of
its own that novakof dreamed of for his language?
So that's a question I want you to keep in your mind.
Is this the same dream or is it somehow different?
So I'm going to leave that there and maybe some,
I don't know,
some chemistry class will show up in here and,
and someone will wonder what that,
what that is and Barth we'll have done his work or we will have done,
uh,
Barthes work for him.
Yeah,
no.
Let me ask you another question.
Who is the narrator of nitesy journey?
Yeah.
Yes.
A sperm.
Did everyone get that?
No.
Okay.
The narrator of nitesy journey is a sperm.
Now we have a story with a sperm as a narrator.
Well I think there are a couple of points,
a couple of reasons why Barth wants to do that.
And actually related to this initial,
your initial point about why you liked this,
that it was,
how did you say that it was the most profound joke?
It is a parody of all the meanings of life.
That philosophy has offered up to us over the ages.
So it kind of runs through them in the voice of our narrator sperms Powell,
who is now gone and dead before him.
So we get a kind of wisdom in a parotic form.
There are other points,
however,
and if you look on page four,
we can see just a little example of one of them.
This sperm has gained quite a vocabulary and it includes,
uh,
this line.
I have seen the best swimmers of my generation go under now.
Where's that from?
Of course,
it's from how I've seen the best minds of my generation love,
blah,
blah.
The point of making a sperm who quotes not only Allen Ginsburg but also hosts of
other prior literary texts is the point that the tradition precedes the
individual speaker.
The individual speaker believes that he has an original voice.
He believes he's speaking in his own voice,
but lo and behold,
his words are not his own.
Okay,
so just as this is a redaction and a compression of all the various meanings of
life that philosophy western philosophy has offered up,
it is also a demonstration of how literary tropes,
literary language,
little packaged bits of literature,
quotations,
illusions,
Lard,
the language that is available to this creature.
His final reflections
on page 12
suggest
his ambition as a speaker and it looks a lot like a modernist ambition.
The bottom of page 12 what has fetched me across this dreadful C is a single
hope gift of my poor dead comrade that you may be stronger willed than I,
and that by sheer force of concentration I may transmit to you along with your
official heritage,
a private legacy of awful reveleigh recollection and negative resolve.
Mad Is,
it may be.
My dream is that some unimaginable in Ma embodiment of myself or myself plus her
if that's how it must be,
we'll come to find itself expressing in however garbled or radical a
translation,
some reflection of these reflections.
Okay.
It's a dream of changing the tradition of having that individual voice added to
the tradition to have it become part of the official heritage and yet at odds
with it casting a different light back.
This is precisely that modernist dream,
specifically articulated by Tsa Elliot and tradition in the individual talent
that the contribution of the individual ads too and changes the tradition in one
swoop.
Is this going to be Barthes ambition too?
This is a question for us again that I want to kind of keep up on the shelf in
your mind.
Okay.
In some way it's a parody of that modernist effort when it comes in the voice of
the sperm because this whole story is a parody,
so you have to ask that question and be somewhat skeptical for all that Barth
looks like.
He embodies that traditional modernist ambition of difficulty of working with
tradition and so on.
He looks like a classic,
late modernist,
but is he really,
this is a question.
Okay.
Ambrose.
His mark purports to be the story of the birth of that being when the sperm from
nitesy journey is United with the egg.
So this is Ambrose's conception that we see the preamble to and in Ambrose,
his mark,
if you look on
page 19,
okay,
you will see that Ambrose has in some sense inherited
some aspect of that sperms remarkable linguistic facility.
He says all that winter,
this was in the middle of the page,
all that winter as I grew in mother's womb,
grandfather fretted with his scheme to get,
uh,
Willie Erdmann is bs.
When the springs first bees appeared on are pussy willows in our older cat cans,
he was off with Hector and Conrad Sauce,
Pan and cheese cloth.
They're researchers led them through fresh marsh,
through pine woods,
over style and under Trussell,
but never a bee tree.
They discovered only swampy impasses or the hives have some part time.
A purist.
He's narrating in great detail what happened while he was in the womb.
Where does this knowledge come from?
It says if his knowledge of his own conception,
his own birth,
his own baby hood is a natural knowledge,
but we must know that it had to come from someone from someone telling stories.
Yeah.
The stories then become part of Ambrose's own account of his own naming and
account of the origin of his identity.
That name Ambrose,
his mark is a reference to Moby Dick in Moby Dick.
When Queequeg signs on to the p Quad,
he makes a mark because he's illiterate in place of writing his name,
signing his name,
and in the novel it says Queequeg his mark.
That's what's written underneath it on the contract.
With that mark quick [inaudible] signs on to the whole trajectory of a Habs mad
pursuit of the whale.
We can think of that in another way as well though with that mark quick,
Craig signs on to the whole trajectory of the 19th century novel,
that whole narrative excess that Melville offers and that whole sense of destiny
that is bound up with a hab story.
What does Ambrose sign up for with his mark?
Well,
the first thing to notice is that unlike Queequeg,
he does not sign that mark the mark here is what he's marked by,
not what he marks with.
And so it's as if the whole tradition comes out and grabs him
and names him.
And so uncle Carl's efforts to interpret the incident of the B
and its relation to the mark on his face suggest the way that certain kinds of
tradition that uncle Carl has been reading probably in the book of Knowledge
Encyclopedia that he sells door to door.
He's a sort of scholarly guy,
um,
that that tradition has named him.
He has no agency
in this,
in this trajectory.
He's entering upon
the effort to take the story of his birth and tell it as if it were natural
knowledge,
is the effort to fight against that lack of agency.
He takes those stories and he makes them his own.
That's an effort at gaining control over what he cannot know about his own
origin and what he cannot choose in his own origin.
I think that's also why Barth chose to write this story in the perfect short
story form and that form is also given to us in lost in the fun house on page 95
when we get the diagram of fry tags triangle.
So if you look at it here on 95 we're told in the course of the story about
Ambrose and Magda and the family,
the action of conventional dramatic narrative may be represented by a diagram
called fry tags,
triangle ABC,
and remember those are the letters from the mobius strip as well or more
accurately by variant of that diagram,
a,
B,
c,
d with Ab representing the exposition and so on and so forth.
If you read on down in that paragraph,
you will see that Ambrose in his frustration,
in his effort to control the story that is always in this story spinning out of
control.
He wants to be able to use for I tags triangle to prop up what has become an
uncontrollable narrative and give it a shape.
He retells even from sentence to the next,
he changes his mind.
He says,
this can't go on much longer.
It can go on forever.
He died telling stories to himself in the dark.
He's dreaming about what will happen to him in the fun house.
Years later when that vast unsuspected area of the funhouse came to light,
the first expedition found his skeleton in one of its labyrinthine Carter
corridors and mistook it for a part of the entertainment.
He died of starvation telling himself stories in the dark,
but unbeknownst,
unbeknownst to him,
an assistant or operator of the fun house happening to overhear him crouch just
behind the ply board partition and wrote down every word,
the operators daughter,
an exquisite young woman with a figure unusually well developed for her age,
Crouch,
judge just behind the partition and transcribed his every word.
He changes the story from one sentence to the next.
Fry Tags Triangle won't help him at all.
Yeah,
so just knowing the form that the story's supposed to take and then knowing that
language has grabbed you.
All these formulaic little phrases,
a figure unusually well developed for her age.
These little stock freezes
there.
What he has to work with even though they are what defeat him in his effort to
make sense of this experience with Magda.
And it is the experience of Magda that produces the problem in the first place.
And so if we look at page 84
oops,
you can see the sort of primal scene of this problem.
This is when he and Magda were having a sort of erotic game.
Yeah.
One summer in the shed they were playing slaves and masters and he was the
master and she was the slave.
Okay.
So he's imagining their future and talking about it with Magda when they're
older.
Okay.
I'm going to start sort of in the middle of the page.
He would be famous,
quite famous in his line of work,
whether Magda was his wife or not.
One evening he was why when he was wise lined and gray at the temples,
he'd smile gravely at a fashionable dinner party and remind her of his youthful
passion.
The time they went with his family to ocean city,
the erotic fantasies he used to have about her.
How long ago it seemed and childish.
Childish yet tender to Nest Po.
That's a Humbert moment.
That's Humbert.
Would you have imagined that the world famous,
whatever remembered how many strings are on the liar on the bench beside girl on
the label of the cigar box,
he'd stared at in the tool shed at age 10 while she age 11 even then he had felt
wise beyond his years.
Another stock phrase,
he'd stroked her hair and said in his deepest voice and correct just English as
to a dear child.
I shall never forget this moment,
but though he had breathed,
heavily groaned as if ecstatic.
What he'd really felt throughout was an odd detachment as though somewhere
someone else we're master strive as he might to be transported.
He had heard his mind take notes upon the scene.
This is what they call passion.
I am experiencing it.
Many of the danger machines,
a digger machines were out of order in the penny arcade's and could not be
repaired or replaced for the duration.
Moreover,
the prizes made.
Now in USA,
it goes off in this strange digression,
it seems like his mind has simply wandered as it does from one version of the
story to another.
But the mention of the machines is not incidental narrative becomes a kind of
machine.
You put your penny in the slot and it works to produce the narrative.
And that's that first part that I read where he's looking back fondly with Magda
from His Eminence later in life and it seems safely past and something that can
be talked about.
But the problem is that even if he could produce that kind of comforting
narrative,
the problem it produced at the level of identity will never be repaired.
Self alienation in Barthes work is the product of desire,
desire,
love.
That's the moment when you're supposed to be perfectly present.
And what happens to Andrew and Ambrose.
That's the moment when he is perfectly a distressingly alienated from himself
and it's the moment when language comes in and is the product of that alienation
or perhaps when language comes in and causes that alienation so he can't
experience an erotic moment without also experiencing it through the screen of
language.
And what he ends up doing is experiencing language instead of sex.
So this is the problem that's never solved in lost in the fun house and it has
all kinds of
ramifications.
This is on 83 just the page before.
Remember this whole story takes place under the aegis of his alienation from
himself.
He's thinking about what he'd like to do in the fun house.
If you knew your way around in the fun house,
like your own bedroom,
you could wait until girl came along and then slip away without ever getting
caught.
Even if her boyfriend was right with her,
she'd think he did it.
It would be better to be the boyfriend and act outraged and tear the funhouse
apart,
not act B.
He's a master diver.
Ambrose said in feigned admiration.
You really have to slave away at it to get that good.
He's playing with Freudian slips,
of course.
What he's thinking about all the times,
the master slave game.
And so here it comes out when he's talking about his brother's diving,
he's a master diver.
You really have to slave away at it.
He can't control the emergence of his desire,
his memory of the desire back into his daily speech.
So he can't control that Freudian slip.
And he also has to correct himself,
remind himself that he wants,
what he wants to do in the fun house is actually not act like the outrage
boyfriend,
but B,
the outrage boyfriend,
this is always the problem for him,
Bros.
He can't just be something.
He is always conscious of inhabiting a performance and it's usually a verbal
performance.
These are the problems that plague mental AEUs so terribly in that final story
that I asked you to read.
So one of the problems with narrative I said earlier when we talked about the
Mobius strip is that it's repetition.
This suggests a kind of exhaustion of language and Ambross is use of these
packaged phrases in lost in the fun house suggest the impossibility of using all
that tradition,
all that stock of language to adequately encounter what daily life will bring
you.
And especially to adequately in habit something like desire.
Barth wrote a famous essay just the year before these stories came out all in
one volume.
They had been written over a series of years,
about five years in the 60s,
and he wrote a very famous essay,
got a lot of exposure,
called the literature of exhaustion.
And there he criticized a lot of the work that was being done and these are the
terms he uses.
Yeah.
Uh,
he said there were two kinds of artists,
ones who are technically up to date and ones that are not,
those who are not right,
a quote turn of the century type novels only in more or less mid 20th century
language and about contemporary people and topics.
This makes them less interesting to me than excellent writers who are also
technically contemporary.
Joyce in Kafka,
for instance,
in their time and in our Samuel Beckett and Jorge Luis Borges.
Okay.
What exhausts language is the failure to keep technically up to date.
And that means in innovation in form Meghalaya ad is where Barth really staked
his claim for innovation.
Yeah.
Those nested layers of narrative that are so off putting on the page that I have
to send you a handout to help you over the weekend.
Otherwise I worry that people will be really lost.
It's very off putting,
but it's precisely those nested stories that allow him to do some of the really
pleasurable things that he can do in that story.
And I would say get at some of the very deep questions raised by the earlier
stories,
uh,
that he finally kind of gets hold of,
to use his own words in,
in this last story.
So I want to begin by thinking about mental laces.
Predicament with Helen,
and this is on one 46.
Yeah.
So he spares Helen's life in Troy and brings her home.
And this is the story that he has been telling.
Okay.
So he says,
I'm gonna.
I decided that I would,
uh,
that I would spare her life,
but and except her groveling for forgiveness instead.
Uh,
so this is the story he's telling himself.
I four bore resolve to accept in lieu of her death,
a modest portion of heartfelt grovel.
Further,
once she'd flung herself at my knees and kissed my him,
I would order her supine and mount more as one who loves than one who conquers,
not impossibly.
She would've quit herself if should she acquit herself.
Well,
and often I would even entertain a plea for her eventual forgiveness and
restoration to the Atria in house.
Accordingly,
I drew myself up to just charge your objection,
whereupon she gave over cleaning her nails and set to drumming them on one knee.
Let your repentance salt my shoe leather.
I said presently and then as I lately she did my blade of anger,
so she view my blade of love.
I only just came aboard.
She replied,
I haven't unpacked yet with our roar.
I went up to Campion way,
a companion way dashed,
stern to stem,
close hold the main flog the smile from my navigator and clove us through the
pastors of the squid leagues.
Thereafter,
when the moon changed phase,
I overtook myself,
determined shrewdly that her Troy chests were secured and vowing this time to
grant the troll.
No quarter at the second watch of night burst into her cubby and four gave her
straight out of the unspeakable.
We'll speak no further.
I declared,
I hear extend to you what?
No other in my position would my outright pardon to which some moments after I
briskly upended disrobe and receive it for the sake of pity.
This offer won't stand forever and of course there are lots of phallic jokes
here.
So,
uh,
I hope you're getting those there.
I had her,
she yawned and responded.
It's late.
I'm tired up the mast half a dozen times I stormed and Sinead took or to my
navigator,
lost sight of Nestor thundered and lightening through Poseidon's Finny feet.
Fif.
When next I came to season,
I stood a night slightly by while she dusk to dawn and it then solution with
this challenge.
Her opening eyes,
man.
Born of woman is imperfect.
On the 3287th night of your Parisian affair,
I lay in some,
some,
uh,
some noises,
some ways med picking vermin off the wound I got that day from a cunning
Pandora's exhaustion,
closed my eyes.
I dreamed myself was pretty Paris plucked by Aphrodite from the field and
dropped into Helen's naked lap there we committed sweet adultery.
I woke wet,
wet,
wept here.
I paused in my fiction to shield my eyes and stanch the Arrow straight tracks.
Claude down my cheek.
Then is one who'd weighted precisely for her malady voice to Horsan.
I out shouted her in these terms,
therefore come to bed by equal on cursing on cursed.
The victory was mine.
I still believe,
but when I made to take trophy,
when did Helen shook her head declaring I have the curse.
She has her period.
My Taffrail oaths took Triton stamp ground.
I fed to the fish.
My navigator knocked my head against the Mo Mo,
the mass and others hollered up a Gail that blew us from laconic Maliyah to
Egypt.
My crew grew restive when the storm was spent.
And I had done flogging me with how Yurds I chose a moment somewhere off snake
had Libya slipped my cloak wrapped at Helen's cabin and in measured toes tones
declared,
forgive me,
adding firmly.
Are you there?
He's pathetic.
He runs through all these stories about himself and as each one fails to win him
back into Helen's cabin,
he comes up with another one.
This is a certain kind of exhausted narrative.
It's the failure of any of these stock narratives to have the effect of
restoring love and desire.
Yep.
But it's
more than that.
It's playful.
It's funny.
Um,
Barthes effort at showing us the exhaustion of narrative produces a kind of new
pleasure in narrative.
So it's by pointing it out and then parodying it that he begins to renew the
resources of fiction.
There are
deeper and more difficult issues at stake though.
And this is in one 55,
we get,
uh,
more serious version of the scene with Magda and the problem of self alienation.
And this is what is really at the heart of mentally assist story.
So remember that the story is that he is obsessed with this question of why
Helen chose him among all her suitors.
Why did she choose him?
And when he asks on their wedding night,
she gives him an answer that only makes him more obsessed with the question.
So at the top of one 55,
he's asked his question speak he commanded,
she whispered love.
Now the problem with that is that answer,
it's a verb and a noun and mental as doesn't know how to take it.
So here
it becomes a verb.
He held her fast.
She took him willy nilly to her.
I feel her yet one endless instant mental aas was no more,
never has been since.
This is like that moment of erotic play with Magda for Ambrose.
It,
it eradicates identity,
eradicate sense of self.
It's gone forever.
And you can see the change in pronouns.
She took him willy nilly to her.
He's telling a story about himself seemingly,
but who's the I then that's leftover.
I feel her.
Yet there's some residual identity leftover that can still have a sense of
embodiment
in his red ear.
Then she whispered,
why'd I weighed you less?
What than who,
et Cetera.
My very question speak mentally as cried to Helen on the bridal bed.
I reminded Helen in her Trojan Bedroom.
I confessed to Ida,
Thea on the beach.
I declared to proteus in the cave mouth.
I vouch safe to Helen on the ship.
I told pisses stratus,
at least,
at least in my sport and hall,
I say to whoever and where I am,
and Helen answered love.
He complied.
He complied as to an order.
She took his course once more to Elysium to fade forever.
Among the feedless.
ASPHODEL is curious.
Fancy alone remained on laid.
When he came to himself.
It's still asked softly why
and don't I cry out to me every hour since.
So that's self alienation causes him to lose his love.
We're told later that he stops sleeping with her because he just can't get it
out of his mind.
He'd rather sit and wonder.
His curious fancy is more active than his desire.
Or you might say,
his desire to know is more active than his desire to love,
but there's a yet yet a complication to this problem.
It's not just about men,
Elias,
and what he chooses to do with his desire.
It's also about Helen and her action and her answer on one 56
yeah,
he reflects,
yeah.
Seven years of this,
more or less,
not much conversation,
something wrong with the marriage.
Helen,
he could hold how hold men Elias to love is easy to be loved as if one were real
on the order of others.
Fearsome mystery,
unbearable responsibility to her.
Mentalis signified something recognizable as Helen to him,
whatever was it.
There's that sense that the other person looking at you,
loving you,
assures you somehow of your reality that you're real,
that you're not an imaginary being.
So it's a way of reminding you that you're not really alienated.
Yeah.
But this is what mentally is,
cannot get his head around.
He cannot understand that he could be loved for no reason.
And proteus sort of gives us a,
uh,
a sense of how we can understand this.
Yeah.
This is on one 61.
Helen chose you without reason because she loves you without cause.
Embrace her without question and watch your weather change.
Let go.
It's a failure of faith in Aphrodite.
So too,
except love is to accept your being and to have faith that love affirms it
affirms that being,
remember that self admonition,
not act like the boyfriend,
but B,
this is what men,
Elias has to ask forgiveness for.
He didn't have enough faith in love just to be and to accept the affirmation of
her,
his being that Helen's reasonableness causeless love embodies.
Barth is asking a really serious question about the compatibility between life
and voice.
Remember that in Ambrose,
his mark Ambrose is saved from the bees lighting on his mouth because his mouth
is on his mother's breast.
He's asleep.
They're having nursed.
It says if the bees,
which signify eloquence,
if they land on your mouth,
they land on his eyes and on his ears instead.
He can't have both that connection with his mother and that kind of eloquence.
It's one or the other.
You can't have love and language somehow.
And this is a very Friday and understanding of how language works.
He tells a story about a child playing what's called the Fort Da game here.
Away he has a little ball,
little two or three year old kid has a ball.
He throws it away and then retrieved that.
He throws it away and retrieves it.
And Freud theorizes that he does that and he says,
Fort Fort Da,
he does that because the language is a way of controlling his mother's absence
and the ball stands in for the mother.
It disappears and then it comes back,
it disappears and comes back.
And at that time,
his mother,
who was actually Freud's daughter was going out to work for the first time on
some days,
uh,
in,
and the boy was getting used to letting her go.
So language arises from that loss.
And Ambrose is only named once,
he separated from his mother and no longer nurses as a,
as a result of the incident.
Yeah.
And he also only gains a male name at that time.
And so I think it's important that the masculinity of language asserted with a
talking sperm at the very beginning of this collection is consistent with this
sense that you become male when you enter into language.
Somehow when you're unnamed,
you're not part of language,
you're still connected to the mother and he actually had a female name.
Remember he's called Christine Awhile,
so he becomes a boy after he separated from his mother metal aliases.
Problem with Helen suggests that in compatibility of being connected to the
other and here across the line of gender
connected with the other and somehow being able to be assimilated into language
and the silence of the Oracle on the question,
who am I?
This is on one 58 and you just get that blank silence and you can see it in
closed in all those quotation marks.
This is Barthes effort to enclose the silence into something readable to contain
that impossibility in the structure of a story.
So all the quotation marks suggest human voice.
I want to suggest to you finally
that Barth is interested in the oral tradition above all other traditions in
this book.
He's using Greek epic as the source of his literary Canon here and his Canon of
stories of narratives because it's oral tradition that brings the human voice
and the human being the fact of a person together most closely.
That's what fascinates him about the spoken word as opposed to the word you
read.
And in other stories in this collection,
Barth experimented with recording them with tape.
So these are stories,
some of them for voice and tape.
And He'd do readings where he'd go and he'd put a tape recorder on the podium
and he'd stand next to the tape recorder as his voice read the story from the
tape recorder.
And it was all to dramatize the problematic relationship between voice,
story and person.
But I think the dream of men alas,
is that somehow that voice can be residual,
that somehow it can survive.
And in that sense,
I think it has something in common with Novakovic fantasy of the living artwork.
But unlike Nebach offs fantasy,
it requires this concept of love because love is what makes being into
narrative.
It takes two and it takes desire,
desire,
moves,
narrative.
And so at the end,
the comic ending of men Iliad,
which,
which echoes the comic ending of Odysseus,
trip back home of the Odyssey.
He says,
mental as a story itself in 10 or 10,000 years expires yet I'll survive it.
Who's this?
I I in Proteus is terrifying.
Last disguise,
beauties,
spouses,
odd Elysium the absurd unending possibility of love.
Okay.
If you think that Barth and all his heady intellectual cononical difficulty is
uninterested in the world outside of his fiction,
I think you could argue that it's on this notion of desire,
that he stakes his works,
connection to the world,
and the echo of that desire is,
I would say pleasure.
Something like in this case,
in a block offs,
aesthetic bliss.
But here it's more funny than that.
It's not even so much the transportation,
the nostalgic quality of Nepal,
coughs description.
Sometimes it's that wit that pleasurable wit,
the pleasure we get reading,
being absorbed by something that we have to work hard to read and yet repays us
with with that pleasure.
Mm.
When you read crying of lot 49 I'd like you to think about what that novel
represents,
uh,
in the relation between language in the world.
Is it similar?
Barth and pension are often talked about as part of the same metal fictional
movement in this couple of decades,
60s and 70s are they assimilable to one another in these terms?
Think about that as you read.